هؤلاء الرجال المغلوبون على امرهم لم
يقترفوا اي ذنب وهؤلاء النسوه الغاضبات لم
يتعرضن للخيانه لكنهم شاركوا في مهرجان
هولي في الهند
احتفالات واسعه تعم البلاد الملايين من
السكان انتشروا في الشوارع والميادين
محتفلين بانتهاء فصل الشتاء واستقبال فصل
الربيع موسيقى ورقص ورشق بالالوان ومعارك
مائيه انه اليوم الاحتفالي المنتظر لكنه
يوم حزين على النساء الارامل يحتفل
بمهرجان هول الهندوسي في الهند ونيبال
وغيرهما من الدول وهو اكثر مهرجانات
الربيع شهره حول العالم تمتد الاحتفالات
السنويه لنحو اسبوعين بين نهايه شهر
فبراير وبدايه شهر مارس من كل عام
من الطقوس الغريبه المصاحبه لمهرجان هولي
احتفالات بضرب الرجال على رؤوسهم من قبل
زوجاتهم في قريه بارسانا شماليه الهند
تحتفل النساء بضرب الرجال بالعصي بينما
يحمي الازواج المغلوبون على امرهم رؤوسهم
بالدروع سيدات القريه يؤمنن باسطوره قديمه
تقول ان الاله كريشنا دايق امراه من
القريه وتعرضته بقيه النساء مستخدمات
العصي واصبح هذا التقليد متبعا بشكل سنوي
رغم كل تلك الاجواء الاحتفاليه يمر
المهرجان حزينا على فئه معينه من المجتمع
انها فئه الارامل في مدينه فرند فان التي
تسمى مدينه الارامل تعيش نحو الفي ارمله
وتحضر التقاليد الهنديه القديمه على
الارامل المشاركه في الاحتفال حيث يعتبرون
وجودهن نذير شوب لكن الارامل في هذه
المدينه كسرنا هذه التقاليد منذ نحو 10
سنين واحتفلنا مع السكان بال الوان والرقص
والقاء الورود
[موسيقى]
احتفال هولي امتد تاريخيا لقرون مخطوطات
من القرن السابع الميلادي اشارت الى طقوس
هنديه قديمه حيث يرشق السكان بعضهم
بالمياه المعطره وينطخون انفسهم بالمساحيق
الملونه المصنوعه من الاعشاب الطبيعيه
للاحتفال جذور دينيه ترتبط باساطير
هندوسيه تحكي عن احراق هوليكا شقيقه ملك
الشياطين بواسطه الاله كريشنا احد اشهر
الالهه الهندوسيه لكن البعض يرجع سبب
التسميه بهولي للغه الانجليزيه التي تعني
المقدس
[موسيقى]
مهرجان هولي اصبح مقصدا سياحيا شهيرا
يتوافد عليه الزوار من انحاء العالم
للاستمتاع وتلطيخ انفسهم بالالوان وربما
يشكل فرصه ذهبيه لبعض النساء اكتشف من
ازواجهم
[موسيقى]